let's get started with this first story
i'm going to start here actually and not
necessarily jump in with the violent
photos but this is part of the same
story
white house refuses to condemn activist
group who posted home addresses of
supreme court justices
we have another story out of maryland in
portland and there are these pregnancy
centers where activists went and smashed
up the windows and damaged them
ransacked them these are places where
they try and talk to women who are
pregnant they're called crisis pregnancy
centers
well activists who are associated with
the pro-abortion side of things
i guess just hate them and so they went
and vandalized and tagged them up i
think seeing stuff like this reach the
highest levels like the white house
where we learned that supreme court
justices had their addresses posted
we've already seen people lose their
lives it shows that we're reaching this
very extreme level of hyperpolarization
so uh daryl i don't know if you've been
following any of the current news about
the roe v wade stuff i mean things have
been kind of crazy over the past couple
of years or you know bill if you've been
following this stuff but i i think we
just get started with this the the
modern uh hyper polarization and i'm
curious what your thoughts are with you
know far left as they would call it or
far right people fighting in the streets
or how about just this right here you
know pro-abortion groups smashing up
windows and vandalizing buildings
well you know that's been going on for
quite some time um
about probably
30 years ago there was an anti-abortion
person
uh who was going up and down the east
coast uh bombing abortion clinics
and uh he got arrested i think down in
florida another one uh murdered an
abortion doctor in florida dr gunn uh
the the guy who um who bombed the
clinics lived lived right in maryland
and um i remember i was in bed one night
at my girlfriend's house
and there was thunder and lightning
and she lived right up against the woods
and we thought a uh a tree had been hit
by lightning
because the whole ground rock the things
fell off the walls everything
four o'clock in the morning
and we jumped up out of bed and then you
know still thunder and lightning and
raining outside so at 7 30 that morning
things had died down we came outside all
the neighbors were out we're all looking
in the woods for this
fallen tree
and
this is on a sunday morning about 4 a.m
it wasn't discovered until monday
in annapolis maryland that uh that guy
had bombed the abortion clinic on the
other side of the woods wow how far away
from your house was it uh from her house
it was um
gosh less than a quarter mile
that's wild yeah it feels like
there are political issues that are kind
of impossible in a sense like
when we talk with people who are
pro-life because we have you know
sheamus on the show periodically and we
have a lot of conservatives and they're
staunchly pro-life
their view of this is
for one most
reasonable people most most people and
particularly like all reasonable people
think bombing an abortion clinic is
wrong and killing people is wrong but
you have
you have moral questions that arise if
the pro-life side genuinely believes
that babies are being murdered
then they're trying to stop murder
now how do you how do you how do you
solve for a problem like that if
you can't convince someone that it's
wrong to bomb a clinic you know what i
mean like if they if they believe in
their heart of hearts that they're
saving babies i don't i don't know if
you can convince them not to commit
these acts
well i think you know that if they
they're convinced that you're murdering
babies
and perhaps they're you know they're not
they're separating babies from adults
so
in their minds i'm not i'm not agreeing
with them i'm saying but in their minds
they're murdering the people who are
murdering babies right so therefore
they're preventing the murder of babies
or if just distracting that's their
justification right
it's like
this is where things are getting
interesting because we talked about this
yesterday louisiana has advanced a bill
that will make abortion homicide that
will legally list it as homicide so this
is
i mean this is a political line that is
as hard as a line can be
because once that line is crossed
that means you have serious questions
about whether or not someone is
justified in using force to stop an
abortion doctor from committing an
abortion
if the act of abortion is homicide then
there's a legal justification to prevent
that from happening that's if it's
codified
regardless of the law though there are
people who already believe that to be
the case
i thought the conversation you guys had
down in nashville sort of theorizing
about future technology
that could potentially enable a fetus to
live at a much earlier age like that is
a fascinating philosophical conversation
that i think people just need to be
willing to have
because but because
that is what it puts it into context
makes it less emotional well the
fascinating thing is uh with this
conversation where
i i basically asked if there was a way
that from the moment of conception a
baby could be taken from the womb and
put into an artificial womb a machine
that would allows it allow it to live
should we then ban abortion
uh to the extent that the baby is killed
and only allow procedures to terminate a
pregnancy if the pregnancy if the baby
is allowed to survive
the the issue with that i suppose is
everyone on the right basically says
like oh okay that's an interesting
question maybe separating from the
mother might be bad but i've asked a
handful of people on the left and they
say meh who cares no i don't know why
not whatever so
not to get into a technological
discussion my question i guess is i'm
trying to get what i'm trying to get
into is
are there issues we can't mend
are are there are there you know just
ideas that we're never going to be able
to to rectify amongst i believe i
believe so i mean you know we can come
close but they're always going to be
issues that that will crop up and then
you know you have
uh what you just proposed there as a
possible viable solution but when you
have things that are that extreme on the
right that extreme on the left
you know you're not going to change
those people necessarily but what you
can do
is
uplift the middle when you have that
extreme polarization then what you want
to do is strengthen the middle pull the
middle up and in doing so you will pull
some of those uh people on the left and
some of those people on the right into
the middle as you do that sort of like a
vortex yeah
yeah i think the have you heard the the
idea that
socialism is able to exist within
libertarianism but libertarianism was
not able to exist within socialism yeah
so i think that that's a pretty
powerful idea i mean i don't necessarily
know one way or the other if it's true
but it seems like
it seems like a true fact what do you
guys think about that idea in a fully
libertarian system you have the right to
create a socialized system with no
problems in a fully socialized system
you've got a lot of checks and balances
you'd have to get through to create a
system where you're like i don't want to
be a part of that unfortunately you have
to because you're already part of it
that's the idea of social absolutely so
one of the issues now in the whole roe v
wade
debate i tweeted about this earlier
we had tim ryan and we had obama i'm
sorry not obama we had jen seki talking
about biden i don't know why i said
obama we had genseki talking about biden
refusing to
uh condemn late late-term abortions she
was asked i think it was by ducey over
at fox news whether
biden was in favor of restrictions on
abortions and she just
you know he-hawed around the answer and
was like it's between a woman a woman
and a doctor woman and a doctor tim
rhines at the same thing so for me
i've always been kind of in the
center-left position it used to be the
left liberal position in this country of
like in the first trimester maybe into
the second second and third trimester
abortion are kind of just not okay
and it's it's supposed to be safe legal
and rare but now you have
one side saying unrestricted up to nine
months the woman is in about to go into
labor the baby can be aborted and then
you have the right saying ban outright
in every circumstance so how do you find
that middle i mean how do you how do you
most people are now finding themselves
like there's no middle there's there's
very few people left
i think well i think part of it you know
depends upon the circumstances as to why
a particular woman wants an abortion
i'm not saying i i don't believe that
all abortion should be uh illegal
i don't believe that all abortion should
be
should happen either but i think it
depends upon the circumstances
if a woman has been raped by a stranger
if a woman has been raped by her father
or as a young girl something like that
uh you know these are mitigating
circumstances it's already bad enough
uh a rape is bad enough that that woman
is going to remember that the rest of
her life is my traumatizer is going to
traumatize her even more
if it's somebody within her own family
her father okay and if uh if that child
is produced
she's going to be confronted with that
child every day as a reminder
is that something that we want you know
that might be a decision for her to make
and not for us to make i suppose the
issue is you know we've we've talked to
a great a great deal this past week
about
the abortion but i think one way to kind
of elevate the conversation is what do
you do when
when you have two competing political
factions that have just moved away from
each other well that's what roe v wade
is sort of bringing up in the cultural
conversation is like
should local
areas make that decision i'm not you
know
it's almost like that's the solution
then to repeal roe v wade i'm or i'm
overturn it
yeah it's just crazy how how
controversial it is and how emotional it
is but we have to have the conversation
i i here's what i think
i think that we mentioned this briefly
the other day if you look at the history
of the united states and personhood that
we have a tendency to move towards
granting more personhood rights
than rescinding them that in almost
every circumstance we are continually
expanding who gets access to what we
deem to be
civil rights it wasn't always the case
in the united states with racism that uh
people weren't granted full civil rights
with women not being able to vote
i actually think that based on the
trends of this country we're going to
move towards completely banning abortion
outright that we'll come to a point
where people agree
that they're going to say we deem a an
unborn baby to be a human life
guaranteed constitutional protection
what was it like before roe v wade daryl
do you remember much about it
yes but vaguely
was it like a big problem was abortion a
hot topic there wasn't so much yeah
there was it was always a hot topic and
and women were were you know getting
abortions in secret uh doing it
themselves with a coat hanger or having
somebody else do it with a coat hanger i
remember friends of mine even did that
you know um and then there were those
who were who are very uh vocal about it
you know they would come out and and say
yeah i had an abortion what about it you
know things like that but it was always
very
controversial and you know they they uh
there were there were a ton of abortion
clinics where you could go and get it
done uh legally and there were always
you know not almost always but a number
of times there would be protests out in
front of the clinics it was particularly
more violent back then wasn't it
in some cases yeah i mentioned the guy i
forgot know what his name was was
michael something who went up and down
the east coast uh bombing the abortion
clinics
um
yeah you know that that part was violent
and killing doctors who uh who performed
abortions
as in dr gunn but but not everything was
was violent you know there were a lot of
loud vocal protests in front of some of
these clinics thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there